[Música]
a
la interrupción parcial o total del
servicio de internet es cada vez más
frecuente en cuba- desde que el internet
móvil llegó a la isla en 2018 se ha
convertido en una herramienta
fundamental de las organizaciones
ciudadanas para expresar sus denuncias y
demandas ejemplo de ello fueron las
protestas del pasado 11 de julio a las
más grandes desde el famoso maleconazo
en 1994 y que lograron organizarse
gracias a las redes sociales justo
después de estas manifestaciones el
gobierno presentó el polémico decreto
ley 35 que impone estrictos controles
por ejemplo prohíbe publicaciones en
redes sociales que a su juicio pueden
dañar al prestigio del país así como la
difusión de lo que las autoridades
consideren como noticias falsas o
contenidos que les resulten ofensivos o
que inciten a movilizaciones u otros
actos que alteren el orden público una
medida que los mismos ciudadanos y
organizaciones defensoras de derechos
humanos han calificado como parte de una
represión digital que restringe la
libertad de expresión
[Música]
desde hace dos décadas los norcoreanos
de a pie pueden conectarse a la red
desde universidades bibliotecas
cibercafés o cada vez más desde sus
propios computadores o teléfonos sin
embargo ellos no se conectan a la world
wide web se conectan a la red one millón
que es como una intranet a es decir una
red cerrada un jardín vallado donde toda
la información debe ser previamente
procesada antes de su publicación en
cuanto los norcoreanos pueden consultar
desde la información meteorológica a
documentos históricos o noticias pero
todo a partir de información previamente
revisada y en muchos casos censurada por
el régimen de este modo en cuanto no
puede leerse sobre el verdadero
desarrollo de la guerra de corea o sobre
el asesinato en 2017 del medio hermano
del líder kim jong-un o sobre las
violaciones de derechos humanos que la
onu atribuye al gobierno de pyongyang
esta información privilegiada está sólo
al alcance de unos pocos elegidos por el
régimen norcoreano para tener acceso a
internet
[Música]
sin es uno de los países que con más
celo controla el contenido de internet
para censurar lo ha aprobado una
sesentena de leyes el año pasado
invirtió 6 mil millones de dólares y
cuenta con cientos de miles de
ciberpolicías el sistema conocido como
gran muralla cibernética impide el
acceso a las webs ilegales y bloquea las
búsquedas de palabras sensibles también
están prohibidos servicios tan populares
en occidente como google youtube o
twitter pero todo ese despliegue tiene
efectos mucho menores de los pretendidos
porque los chinos son expertos a la hora
de eludir la censura ya sea modificando
ligeramente los caracteres de las
palabras buscadas oa través de vpn esos
programas que permiten conectarse a
servidores extranjeros así que esa
presunta gran muralla cibernética es en
realidad un enorme queso de gruyère
[Música]